jean marc bonjour heureux de vous
retrouver dans la matinale de rtl france
est la france va donc continuer de
s'endetter en 2021 ce qui préoccupe
beaucoup d'observateurs qui voit mal
comment elle va supporter un tel
endettement
alors première question à combien se
monte la dette publique dans le pays
aujourd'hui
bah écoutez le quoi qu'il en coûte
d'emmanuel mâcon comment ça c'est vrai a
coûté très cher on en est aujourd'hui à
plus de 3000 milliards d'euros au total
c'est à dire 120% du pipe c'est à dire
plus d'un an de richesses créées c'est
assez historique alors l'année dernière
on a dû emprunter environ 200 milliards
d'euros principalement pour financer
vous visiez tout à l'heure les halles
aux entreprises le chômage partiel
et puis aussi toutes les pertes de
recettes fiscales puisqu'il ya
pratiquement eu très peu de tva pas de
csg pas d'impôt sur les sociétés puisque
l'activité était était figé alors cette
année 2021 on va devoir emprunter
presqu'autant un peu plus même parce que
les prévisions d'activité sont moins
bonnes que prévu
on voit bien que le virus a du mal à
sortir du jeu on voit bien qu'on a du
mal à mettre en place des plans de
vaccination rapide
il faut donc continuer à supporter des
entreprises qui sont en panne il va
falloir s'occuper des entreprises qui
était très malade avant le coc vide qui
volettent encore davantage après pour
essayer d'amortir ce chômage qui
risquent d'apparaître
il va falloir commencer aussi et surtout
à financer le plan de relance destiné à
accompagner toutes ces mutations
industrielles digital écologique
il y en a encore pour plus de 100
milliards alors y en aura à peu près le
tiers qui sera payé par l'union
européenne mais quand même 100 milliards
c'est un moindre chiffre parce que
beaucoup d'économistes notamment ceux de
l'om je pense qu'il faudra mettre plus
que 100 milliards donc sur deux ans fait
le calcul de 100 milliards l'année
dernière plus de 200 milliards cette
année
on est à quatre cents entre 400 et 500
milliards c'est quand même gigantesque
ses vertiges idole alors question très
basique mais jean-marc ma question
évidente
comment est ce qu'on fait alors avant de
vous répondre
il faut rappeler quand même vu cet
argent n'a pas été perdue on l'a passée
par les fenêtres il a servi à soutenir
les entreprises
il a soutenu servi aussi sur toi à
soutenir le
balshaw c'est quand même assez paradoxal
le pouvoir d'achat n'a pas baissé en
2021 et les contrats de travail ont été
et préservé on a l'impression que c'est
normal tout ça mais la france est un des
pays au monde qui a le plus compenser
toutes ces blessures de la crise
maintenant vous avez raison à la
question c'est dimanche soir payer et
tous ceux qui viennent nous raconter
qu'on ne paiera pas il raconte des
sornettes
soit ils manipulent soit il faut dans la
démagogie il faudra payer d'une façon ou
d'une autre
alors comment ça peut se passer bien
vous avez en gros deux écoles vous avez
deux scénarios le premier scénario il
est hyper classique et perd orthodoxe
tout le monde y pense ça consisterait à
prévenir l'opinion publique ma foi bombe
à l'époque du quoi qu'il en coûte va se
terminer on a déjà un peu commencé je
sais pas si vous avez remarqué
et il faut se préparer à des efforts des
sacrifices mais on risque de perdre
notre souveraineté ex si on continue
d'emprunter parce que 50 % plus de 50%
de la dette est une dette étrangère mais
quand vous paie quand vous payez vous
quand vous ne payez pas vos banquiers
bas il serait il revient vers vous et
puis vous demande des comptes alors dès
que la crise sanitaire va se calmer
il va falloir urgemment diminuer la
dépense publique et sociale trouver des
recettes alors on a des gens à bercy qui
ont beaucoup d'imagination pour faire
tout ça on pense bien sûr à une
augmentation des impôts
on pense aussi à puiser dans les
épargnes des particuliers qui est
importante sous forme d'un emprunt
obligatoire par exemple ça c'est le
scénario le plus classique le plus
orthodoxe mais je pense qu'il nous mène
directement à de grandes difficultés
même à une catastrophe économique
pourquoi pas parce que l'austérité en
pareil cas bloquent complètement le
redémarrage de l'économie
alors si on ne peut pas financer par
l'impôt ou le travail comment est ce
qu'on peut faire
eh bien vous avez des économistes et non
des moindres qui imagine un deuxième
scénario qui sont d'ailleurs en train de
le discuter avec l'elysée avec bercy
je pense notamment à jean tirole le prix
nobel d'économie
je pense à olivier blanchard qui a été
le chef économiste du fmi il pense que
le remboursement lui de cette bête
peuvent s'étaler sur plus de dix ans et
sans beaucoup de douleur sans beaucoup
dollar paraît paradoxal mais à trois
conditions et c'est très sympa très
technique je vais vous expliquer il faut
que l'endettement ne s'accroisse plus
actuellement
il continue de s'accroître on l'a bien
vu 200 milliards encore cette année
mais si ça ne sera plus si la crise
sanitaire se résorbe et bien on pourra
arrêter s'endetter quand même puisque la
croissance viendra il faut que les taux
d'intérêt et ça c'est très important
reste à 0 reste bas actuellement ils
sont négatifs
la dette s'accroît mais là charges
financières diminuent
c'est assez paradoxal plus on n'emprunte
plus on s'enrichit en quelque sorte
n'empêche qu'on a quand même un stock de
dettes à rembourser et la troisième
condition mais il faut que la croissance
revienne mais la croissance va revenir
dès que le virus aura disparu il ya vu
au moment du des confirmands et si la
croissance revient avec des taux
d'intérêt qui resteront à 0,1 et bien le
montant de la dette va diminuer
mécaniquement sans faire aucun effort et
on a dix ans pour ça parce que cette
date est une dette à maturité de 10 ans
et ce n'est que dans dix ans qu'il
faudra la renouveler alors dans dix ans
on verra si les taux d'intérêt souvent
port à 0 mais s'ils ne sont plus à 0 et
qu'on à diminuer le stock de la dette
on pourra quand même respirer on a dans
le dix ans pour que cette date qui est
une qui ne résonne le phénomène des taux
zéro c'est le remède miracle aujourd'hui
pour tous les pays du monde
alors vous allez me demander à part
pourquoi il ya des taux zéro eco est
qu'on a des chances de les garder aussi
longtemps c'est ça la marque pourquoi il
y avait tous 0 1
alors je vais faire très très court vous
avez des taux zéro d'abord parce que les
banques centrales ont beaucoup pour
courage et le mouvement en récupérant
des vieilles dettes et en mettant de la
liquidité à la disposition des états
mais les boks centrale en fait
n'explique pas tout il ya des pauses
héros parce qu'il ya beaucoup d' épargne
dans le monde entier il ya beaucoup d'
épargne pour deux raisons la première
raison c'est que vous avez une
démographie mondiale qui vieillit dans
le monde entier et des seniors c'est à
dire les vieux mais les seniors ça
consomme moins ça gagne sans doute un
peu plus d'argent que les jeunes et ça
et pas davantage cette épargne est
disponible actuellement
deuxième raison est bien on est en
pleine révolution digitale et la
révolution digitale voyez vous ça
accroît la productivité et la
productivité c'est de la richesse et la
richesse et bien ses choix consommer
choix épargné s'il ya plus de richesses
sur a forcément
patch donc on a des chances de conserver
des taux très bas des taux zéro encore
pendant pas mal d'années
merci beaucoup jean marc jean marc
sylvestre on vous retrouve tous les
mercredis matins dans l'édito de la
matinale